one of the most powerful things that I
think this research points to is the is
the absolute importance of the brand
because the brand is what allows someone
to make a shortcut brand formation is
very difficult and branding is probably
one of the most successful things
markers ever came up with the idea that
you know people will be able to make a
decision that might even be very
complicated it was like buying a flat
panel television you know do I do plasma
LED do i do you know or don't wait for
new technology do i do whatever but what
happens is you go oh it's a sony so
that's going to row its own mitsubishi
or it's a Panasonic and so when you
start looking at let's say a new
manufacturer coming into that space you
know how do they how do they claim space
so what they normally do is they is
they'll they'll pick something like
maybe low price and so where some people
are going to come in and shop off a
brand other people going to come in and
shop off of that low price it's going to
be kind of a shortcut decision oh well
you know that one's a thousand dollars
less so you know I'll buy that one and
that the amount of that the distance
between that you know that entry price
and what the other guys charge and its
really the value of the brand and then
once you create that brand you know that
entry point then you've got to work your
way up and it's like the Korean
Automobile Manufacturers you know as
they're trying to create that brand
equity in the United States you know
they're really pushing hard at you know
more quality but it was hard for them so
they came out with a hundred thousand
mile guarantees and no warranty so that
was that was their way of kind of
appealing to the conscious brains
concern so that the unconscious brain
could actually get in there and automate
that decision
you